nadar en el sena es una actividad
actualmente prohibida pero que pronto
será autorizada entre estos nadadores se
encuentran dos miembros del gabinete de
la alcaldesa de París han Hidalgo tres
zonas de baño en el río abrirán sus
puertas en la capital francesa en 2025
varios meses después del final de los
Juegos Olímpicos
es muy agradable en nadar allí el agua
está a 22 grados es muy agradable Así
que creemos que tenemos todas las
condiciones necesarias para crear unas
zonas de baño estupendas
las autoridades municipales prohibieron
el baño en el sena hace un siglo debido
a la contaminación del agua que plantea
importantes riesgos para la salud pero
un proyecto de limpieza de 1500 millones
de dólares que comenzó en 2016 está
dando sus frutos según las autoridades
nadamos
hace quincena pero aquí está más limpia
hay plata Durante los Juegos Olímpicos
de 2024 El sena participará en tres
pruebas entre ellas el triatlón y la
natación en aguas abiertas tras la justa
olímpica se pondrán a disposición de
residentes y turistas zonas de baño
equipadas con vestuarios y duchas